welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki is evolving from the god
of Mischief into the god of stories a
transition unfolding in Loki season 2 as
our hero plays a pretty big role in the
founding of the TVA as a sciencefiction
dream project of OB AKA author ad Doug
whose Caltech jet propulsion lab is the
same building structure of the TVA
ground level RNA department so we've
been asking if it was OB or Kang variant
Victor timley or he remains who created
the TVA but now it seems like at least
it's spiritual Godfather was God of
stories Loki in the act of putting the
right book in the right hands in this
video I'm going to explain what God of
stories means to the Marvel World why
fiction is more powerful than science
and how the TVA truly came into
existence to support new rock stars grab
this UB inspired we're all going to die
shirt at nerd rot. shop also if you're
in the LA area we are doing a live show
on Thursday November 16th at brain dead
Studios come hang out with me and with
Tommy and others from the new Rockstar
team it's going to be a lot of fun to
talk about this season of Loki the
Marvels everything okay Loki season 2
episode 5 reveals that OB or aoris
originated as ad Doug a Caltech
professor of theoretical physics in 1994
and a struggling science fiction author
of books like the zeran contingent and
the sons of urine working out of a
Pasadena area JPL lab in a remote area
with the building interior looking
exactly like the interior of the RNA
Department of the TVA the name ad Doug
is almost certainly a nod to Douglas
Adams a science fiction author of
hitchiker's guide of the Galaxy the ser
that very much inspired the quirky
science fiction workplace comedy themes
of the Loki series and yes established
the number 42 as the answer to the great
question of light the universe and
everything 42 we've been noting
throughout the season of Loki pops up in
the protocol 42 that was he remains
memory white protocol that he tells Miss
Min to perform on Ren Slayer and section
42 was the part of the temp pad design
that was giving Loki and Mobius so much
trouble ad Doug has the perfect
background in science and in science
fiction to be the imagineer behind the
tva's initial design but like all things
in the tva's history this season it is
itself an Ora Boris a snake eating its
own tale a grandfather Paradox Victor
timley in 1893 said that he was inspired
by Ora Boris who wrote the TBA handbook
that Ren Slayer gave him or Boris in the
TBA said in episode 4 that he learned
everything he knew from the 19th century
inventor Victor timely so who inspired
who well episode 5 takes this a layer
deeper it was Loki who inspired OB
before he was ever a TVA employee by
giving him a TVA handbook to inspire him
to build that first Tad that handbook
was of course the combined knowledge of
both OB and of Victor timley but it was
Loki who in this 1994 Branch timeline
gave it to an uninitiated professor and
author to do something greater with his
life ad Doug at first interprets this as
a character from his Fiction come to
life of course I believe you it's a
dream come true one of my characters has
come to life and needs my help but it's
not that ad Doug literally dreamt up
Loki it's just that Loki reminds him of
his own fictional writings and this
scenario doesn't weird him out that much
Loki begins this episode dismissing the
whole idea of fiction writing you a
writer yes science fiction I'm doomed
but his Arc throughout this episode is
to gradually see The Virtue in
controlling one's own narrative with
science it's all what and how but with
Fiction it's why we're all writing our
own stories now go write yours it was a
fiction problem it's not about where
when
or
why it's about who by transitioning Loki
into the god of stories this Arc is
adapting the Loki agent of Asgard
storyline starting in 2014 which changed
Loki's status in the Modern Marvel comic
era from the god of Mischief into a more
benevolent God known as the god of
stories he fuses with the allseen eye
and comes to terms with all past and
future versions of himself reborn as
Loki god of stories his magical
abilities now enable him to perceive
manipulate even fully rewrite stories
giving him a kind of new meta role
similar to that of the The Watcher and
this isn't just the Thematic parallel
we're pulling out of our ass here this
episode explicitly established that B1
15's name before she joined the TVA was
Dr Verity Willis first she was just kind
of a New York pediatrician named Dr
Willis but in this episode's end credit
visuals her ID establishes her first and
last name as Varity Willis who also
appears in the Loki agent of Asgard run
as a member of a family tasked with
guarding relics like the casket of
ancient Winters and a ring that allows
the wearer to see through any lie Varity
as a baby eats this ring it dissolves in
her stomach giving her these innate
powers to see through Loki's
this leads to Loki dropping his god of
Mischief function and he ends up
becoming the benevolent God of stories
which is now technically a status in
Marvel Comics Canon so by turning Loki
into the god of stories I think this
episode establishes for us the one thing
we are missing in the tva's origin
mythology mythology truly Cosmic
mythological Roots a Godfather an Alla
now long time new rockstars viewers know
how much we use geology and how long
we've been using it for but if this is
your first time hearing about about
geology get ready for Blockbuster
quality skincare on a student film
budget geology is a 23 time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oiless prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you in the
pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skincare or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30 second quiz right now if you
use the code new rockstars 100 geology
will give you 100% off their
award-winning skincare trial set you'll
also get an additional bonus offer of up
to 30% off one skin hair or body
products when you add it to your trial
it's truly a wild offer one of the best
they've ever given our audience so click
the link in the description or go to GE
log. i/ rockstars 100 to get started in
episode 3 Loki grumbled upon seeing the
attendees of the 1893 World's Fair
celebrating other Asgardian Gods like
Odin Thor balder the brave but not Loki
Mischief it seems isn't the stuff of
legend in the same way Loki's Arc this
whole season is to redefine his legacy
and acquire a new active glorious
purpose and it's not enough for that
purpose to just be to prevent what's
coming it needs to be something that
serves his own selfish interest it can't
just be science is behind the story of
the TVA because a textbook alone will
never completely provide catharsis to a
viewing audience who come to these
stories in search of meaning Kang
variant he remains role as the head of
the TVA before was that of a playwright
a screenwriter a fiction writer and
there needs to be a source of that
narrative fiction at the tva's
conception so the order of operations is
Loki god of stories gives the book to ad
Doug author of Science Fiction liken
with Douglas Adams a book that then goes
to Victor timley whose future is to be a
Shakespearean play right the book itself
is kind of an empty McGuffin at least
spiritually the only reason it matters
is whose hands have been on it and who
has applied its knowledge this episode
showed us the god of stories without
realizing writing the story of the TVA
he inspired a Caltech theoretical
physics teacher to build the first temp
pad ad Doug then clearly modeled his
workstation in the TVA on his jet
propulsion lab and likely used the bones
of it in construction of the ground
floor of the entire TVA and I still
maintain that the whole purpose of this
institution at first from the
perspective of ad dg/ OB is a benevolent
purpose to oversee to monitor a chaotic
Multiverse rather than to prune it and
we can also look at this episode as Loki
getting credit for recruiting TVA
Employees mob sb15 KC and OB from their
Origins as Don Dr ver Willis Frank
Morris alcatra escape and AD Doug M's
description of jetskis as a beautiful
Union of Form and Function might have
come from Loki telling him these words
this episode a beautiful Union of form
and function now we shouldn't give Loki
too much credit because I think this
story was mostly written by OB as a
science fiction novelist it was Kang
varant T remains who adapted that story
into a screenplay to make the Hollywood
big bucks but it was God of stories Loki
who handed that inspiration to the
novelist ad Doug to make him believe in
himself so I am going to write a
bestseller yeah sort of and that's what
we need most from a Godfather and from
an allfather again we got a live show
Thursday November 16th come hang out
with us in Los Angeles grab this OB
inspired shirt we're all going to die
from nerd rot. shop follow me on all
social platforms at eaos subscribe to
all three channels in the new rockstars
Network thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
bye